I have some questions for you things
have been dying to know Taylor asked
questions and delivered lots of answers
of her own in the September issue of
Vogue now we're breaking down seven
things we learned from her spread
starting with this
Taylor's NYC apartment is cool AF the
reporter notes that the interview took
place in her Tribeca loft which was a
former printing house calling the space
warm and cozy and vaguely literary how'd
I do that
oh she also has a garden and she says
her wardrobe is so epic it looks like it
might open up to gnarnia casual me to
the pop star also opens up about the
months-long social media campaign to
cancel her following her twitter
confrontation with kim kardashian I
would very much like to be excluded from
this narrative you know the one the one
where Kim called Taylor a snake quote a
mass public shaming with millions of
people saying you are quote unquote
cancelled is a very isolating experience
you're sending mass amounts of messaging
to this person to either shut up
disappear or it could also be perceived
as kill yourself number three on our
list swifty says that her newest album
lover feels like a new beginning and
might just be her favorite album yet
have a new album coming out
quote this album is really a love letter
to love in all of it's maddening
passionate exciting enchanting horrific
tragic wonderful glory next up in an
accompanying video Taylor reveals that
Vogue's editor-in-chief Anna Wintour was
the in SPO behind this red-carpet look
how did you really feel when I copied
your hairstyle at the 2016 Grammys
Taylor I am being very very honest and I
would like to tell you that I was on it
oh and you know all that recent drama
between Taylor and Scooter Braun over
the rights to her masters well she talks
about that too
when asked if she tried to get her
master's from her previous record label
big machine she explains why she chose
to strike a deal with Universal instead
quote it was either investing in my past
or my and other artists future and I
chose the future
and yep she's talking about putting her
beef with Katy Perry in the past
[Music]
Tayler explains how the media had a
heavy hand in their feud quote it's like
they're pouring gasoline all over the
floor all that needs to happen is one
false move one false word one
misunderstanding and a match is lit and
dropped that's what happened with us
[Music]
and last but not least on our list
tailor addresses the public scrutiny
over her lack of involvement in the 2016
presidential election and explained she
stayed quiet because she thought she
might be a liability quote the summer
before that election all people were
saying was
she's calculated she's manipulative she
is not what she seems she's a snake
she's a liar these are the same exact
insults people were hurling at Hillary
would I be an endorsement or would I be
a liability I have some questions for
you
things have been dying to know I think
the Internet will agree with me
literally millions of people were
telling me to disappear so I disappeared
in many senses I liked seeing this
candid tell-it-like-it-is side of Taylor
of course we'll be here to make sure
you're up to date on all the latest
swifty news so make sure to keep it
locked right here on UT until next time
I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]